All right.
This morning,
a haircut,
a slam dunk
and a real San Antonio barbecue.
According to her agent,
that is how Brittney Griner is
spending her first weekend
back on US soil.
After she was detained
in Russia for ten months.
Griner, as you know,
landed in Texas on Friday
after she was part of a prisoner
She'd been taken to a medical ev
at a U.S. military base in San A
And she has since moved into a m
residential area.
We were told she is a Christmas
Her agent says she's upbeat.
She's thankful, she's hopeful.
CNN's senior political correspon
and anchor of Inside Politics
Sunday, Abby Phillip is here.
Obviously, Abby, you interviewed
Brittney Griner,
whose wife, Cheryl,
while she was detained.
And so, you know, the family wel
And, you know,
you've been talking to her agent
about what this experience has b
And I just wonder what they want
What did she want to do
when she got back?
What are some of the ways
she's been spending our time her
It seems like,
Caitlin, they're really just try
to kind of
give her a taste
of what her normal life was like
One of the very first things
that she did was have Dr.
Pepper after getting off that pl
Look,
it was a really emotional day
for everyone involved.
She was greeted
when she landed by her wife
and her agent. It was a very sma
But over the weekend,
that group really expanded
to include her broader family,
who I'm told spent many,
many hours with her.
They brought her that barbecue.
One of the interesting things
that I learned in talking to her
agent over
the weekend was actually
while she was in Russia,
her Russian lawyer, in an attemp
of make her feel
a little bit more at home,
learn how to make brisket for he
and slow
cooked brisket for her
and gave it to her.
Obviously, it was nothing like S
Antonio barbecue,
but she got the taste of the rea
this weekend.
This is going to be a really lon
And I think that everyone around
right now
is focused
on her physical rehabilitation.
I'm told she is
physically doing quite well,
but also her psychological rehab
and making her feel more
in control of her life.
That's part of this,
you know, government program
that other detainees
like Trevor Reid have gone throu
Brittney Griner
is going to go through that prog
for as long as she wants it,
really to try to rebuild her
sense of self after detention.
You know,
this is a obviously
this would be a life altering th
for anyone Abbie. Right.
I found I find this interesting
and I wonder how this changes he
My question is going to be,
how does this change her into th
You would
you would expect
it would be okay
if someone wanted to go inside t
and just close off.
But I found it
interesting that
she wanted to immediately,
even on the plane,
reach out to other people,
fight for other people.
She said, I want to relate to pe
So I'm wondering if this takes h
in a different way
into a similar direction as mayb
Colin Kaepernick
where you fight for the larger t
rather than just the sport.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Yeah, absolutely.
And, you know,
that was one of the clearest thi
that I gathered
from talking to people around he
And you even heard it from Shery
when she was at the White House
on Friday.
This changes everything.
You know,
Brittney Griner
in the world of WNBA
and the world of basketball
is a pretty big name, a pretty b
But but I think even more so now
her notoriety is global,
and she understands
the responsibility that comes wi
and has been pretty clear.
She wants to use what power
she has to help other people.
They are now part of this commun
It's a community of families.
Dozens of them across the countr
whose loved ones are detained
all across the world.
Some of those individuals
never came home.
They died in detention.
And so I think the weight of tha
she she carries that with her.
And her agent told me
that she asked about Paul
Leland immediately upon being fr
And she's known for a long time
that or believed for a long time
that her fate was very much tied
And I think was heartbroken
that he was not brought home
along with her.
And so
she's very committed
to that particular case.
But I was
told is planning to use her plat
the bully pulpit,
that she has to help others
in the future.
And that's going to change her
her approach to her public life.
It's not just going to be activi
you know, in Phenix
that I think a lot of athletes,
you know, participate in.
I think
it's going to have a global scop
Hey, before you go,
I just want to ask you real quic
and maybe
I don't know if you can answer t
I'm sure they'll be paying atten
to the Respect
for Marriage Act
because they don't know
if you've got a question her
about it, but can you react to t
Well, you know, I mean,
I think that they are definitely
to be paying attention to that.
I mean,
I think that as a,
you know, a
lesbian black woman,
they have become a really promin
you know, image of
love in the LGBTQ community.
And, you know,
one of the things just meeting
just on a personal note,
meeting Cheryl and just seeing h
that love that they have for eac
was able to withstand
this incredible trial.
Cheryl calls
Brittney Griner her best friend.
They were friends for a long tim
before they became a couple.
And so for this to happen
and for them to be reunited toda
I think it's an important moment
for both of them.
And it's an important moment
for the country, I will say.
Don, I just want to add one thin
Her agent was really clear with
She was like,
I don't think that Brittney
was treated differently
because she was black
and she was lesbian in Russian d
That's something
I think a lot of people are payi
attention to.
And it was notable to me that sh
that I saw that in your reportin
Very good stuff. Yeah.